[Music]
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
the lobby game spots weekly video game
hangout i'm your host mike mccarty we
have a lot of star wars stuff to talk
about today uh we're so glad you're here
as usual we have the twitch chat open
youtube chat game spot chat if you're
joining us
please feel free to participate we
always love comments questions and
concerns i'm here with pete brown i love
concerns yeah what are your concerns
this week
uh there's a lot of reviews to get out
there's a lot of games coming out um
some remakes well remastered i guess
some new stuff oh like does the
afternoon came out full throttle
remastered yep um voodoo vince which
we're not doing a review of the favorite
game ever yeah what's it about
i don't know that game really don't know
um boy named vince dawn of war three is
next week right dawn aboard three is
next week the review will be up tomorrow
outlast two is soonish yes review will
be at next week things are ramping up a
little bit before like pray hits
mario kart eight it's coming up part
eight kelly you're writing maggie over
there kelly that's me i've been playing
a lot of mario kart 8. um deluxe
i'm a big mario kart fan
and i'm ready to crush the opposition
yeah that's what i'm about perfect
when's that review going up that is
going up tomorrow okay please help me
rob handlery
i can't help you on that our resident uh
street fighter expert no oh mike star
wars we bring you on for uh for some
star wars talk today i like star wars
yeah you uh how many times did you watch
the new trailer for last jedi last jedi
um
quite a few not as much as i watched the
first force awakens trailer um but man
that movie is looking good last jedi i'm
pretty pumped pretty pumped yeah uh
as usual we have a giveaway which are
already modeled right here we have some
pixel pals uh chun li and ryu
if you want to get after these shiva
will be tweeting from our gamespot
twitter account uh if you
follow us
then retweet that tweet and later on the
week we'll pick a random winner
in north america but also if you don't
follow us follow us and uh if you're in
the twitch chat shiva usually puts that
in there she's uh khaleesi plays and
yeah so hopefully you win that later in
the week we can get those off the table
now i guess rob if you don't mind uh
cool got some news items i want to get
through as usual before we get to the
main segments uh
sad day in the world of classic nintendo
games nintendo kind of without
explanation as far as i have seen
discontinued the nes classic
at first it was just north america and
japan but then they confirmed after
people reached out to him that it's
europe and just worldwide in general uh
it's been plagued by supply issues since
launch which
you know a lot of people
i don't know if this a lot of people
kind of say that nintendo tries to
create that illusion of demand that
might be giving them too much credit but
do you have any idea why this might have
been a problem with this was it
something was it too
was it coinciding with the switch launch
or what people have a lot of different
theories yeah one of them being that
this was a really good way to drum up
interest in nintendo right before switch
came out um
i think zelda kind of did that on its
own yeah uh some people are saying that
maybe they're working on the super
nintendo mini and they're trying to
focus their efforts on manufacturing
that but
yeah i don't know it's really not clear
it's one of those decisions which it
makes you scratch your head and say oh
nintendo i guess
yeah we uh someone actually tweeted at
me for the show today asking what games
we want to see on super nintendo i
actually tabled that because i'm sure
once if we do get the announcement then
we'll talk more about that then uh but
yeah that was josh lopez uh thank you
for the question but like i said we'll
table it for another episode because
it's probably gonna be more relevant
coming weeks months or whenever they
decide we just need super metroid and
chrono trigger that's it
isn't the subscription for nintendo like
one classic game a month or something
like like that too on the switch
so we're like we're in the middle of
like an online trial period where
everyone gets to use online stuff for
free i guess mario kart 8 is going to be
the first game to take advantage of
online play
yes or maybe maybe not the first but
maybe like the first major one but
within this period and then once we
start paying for a subscription you're
supposed to get one game a month it's
been a month and a half now no free game
so who knows what's happening i don't
think we're gonna see a virtual console
i think we're gonna see these games
released just on their own as little
classic titles
uh in other news bandai namco they were
kind of teasing a new game with the
tagline prepare to dine
trolls which i'm sure caught us all this
is getting kind of hot i love it it has
since been announced as code vane by the
same developer as the god eater series
uh shift developer team shift uh and it
will be a dungeon crawler-like
experience with rpg elements uh i mean
the first thing that a lot of people
hear when they hear that is dark souls
but obviously you can tell this is very
stylistic
um i'm not sure
whether it's going to be i mean they
haven't said too many other details
aside from the general genre but i don't
know it looks promising looks stylish i
love her
what's her name waifu
that's her name is waifu
uh
that looks cool
and also kind of leading into our first
segment uh call of duty the new dlc new
zombies map is out as of today yesterday
yes yesterday okay so if you haven't
played it yet we are doing a stream
later scott butterworth will be and joey
i believe joey will be playing with some
of the zombies developers yeah you know
say what you will about the game itself
but zombies here is
really fun just coming back to this
every time i actually uh really enjoy
they put a lot of time
and just content into these maps this
one's kind of 80s disco funk
uh themed which a little bit of kill
bill kung fu in there
big trouble
yeah i mean i'm a huge disco funk fan
and just getting it's like there's a
disco dance floor and it's i believe
it's the tramps the song um
burn baby burn i believe that's the
tramps
uh i love that song so much so just
hearing that i'm sure you turned the
power on and they're gonna dance on the
dance floor right there i think hell
yeah yeah
if uh human beings comes on um
nobody but me the song that plays while
she's breakdown sword fighting the crazy
88 and it's also the song that leo
dicaprio puts that dude from rhode
island
he puts him through the fridge in uh the
departed it's a very
it's a popular song to use prolific song
yeah
i really like zombies in spaceland i'm
excited to play this yeah so uh this is
out as of now you can go play this on
xbox one
ps4 and also in the world of dlc near
automata released something fittingly
weird for this game you can fight the
square enix ceo yosike yosuke matsuda
and the platinum ceo
kinichi sato you can fight them as
bosses in this dlc
so this prompted the question
what are some of the weirdest dlc packs
we've ever played because there have
been some odd ones are we going to show
some of the okay here we go we're gonna
get into the actual fight of it because
i watched it this morning look at that
is it square or that's the square enix
ceo so that's
so ridiculous
oh he just told me
um so like they fight with a mix of just
like hand-to-hand martial arts but they
also can emit like
clouds of drones that are just their
heads which you can see right here oh my
god that's what we need all right but
have you guys played much of this game
because i know that
it's said time and time again that
despite the slew of awesome releases
this year this game is fantastic i
played i was telling rob before the show
i've been playing a lot more of it like
between persona 5 bouts this game is
really really good and
all the weird [ __ ] in it just feels so
right for this game yokotaro he's done
other stuff like that he did um
drakken guard drakengard yeah it's like
his style but i don't know i i don't
know if i'll get the time to play this
dlc yet but
damn level 85 is i mean it sounds high
but that's funny here's platinum ceo and
president
i like how he's just motionless
descend from the sky
yeah that's awesome oh you think the
same time
yeah yeah if we stick with this the
fight looks like super just chaotic and
the player ultimately dies in this clip
stop trying to hit me and hit me yeah
you end up some guy was watching the
matrix on a flight the other day and it
got stuck in my head do you think that's
a game you're playing
and then you watch matrix uh reloaded
and then i fell asleep
i uh i stopped using my spare time
playing this to try to play more persona
and i'm feeling like
not that that's a mistake but maybe i
want a shelf persona for now and go back
to this game i yeah i'm kind of having
that same debate i just
there's a lot of games the beginning of
this year that are going to take up a
lot of time to play like right i'm still
playing zelda and i i'm trying to finish
that so i can move on basically but i'm
not sure if i want to move on to persona
or to this
um and i kind of want to move on to this
looking at this battle because i want to
fight a ceo's head
is this in-game like
this seems like a ridiculous arena like
dungeons yeah i mean judging by how the
rest of the game is structured it might
just be something you travel to in the
open world but yeah like you said it
just seems pretty basic coliseum kind of
thing but yeah this is one of those
games that uh i mean
riot in the twitch chat was just saying
it needs to be in the game of the year
discussion i totally i mean i know it's
only what is it april i know it's only
april but this is definitely one of
those games that i don't want to let get
overshadowed by all the other very
fantastic games coming out this year but
i think there's any question it's one of
the best out of the third of the year
that's passed yeah and it's great for
platinum because they've kind of had a
rough between uh we talk about this all
the time scalebound being canceled on
xbox one and also the last release i
think was tmnt turtles in manhattan
mutants in manhattan i always forget the
name but i didn't play it uh anyway yeah
so we wanted to talk about other
weird dlcs we've played throughout the
years because there are
there's quite the plethora of them uh
the first one i want to talk about and
it's quite popular is undead nightmare
for red dead redemption uh essentially
did you guys play this
no no okay yeah well it essentially just
kind of re-skinned red dead redemption
and put zombies on it back in the middle
of the zombie's heyday after like left 4
dead and dead rising were huge
um i liked it it was
it was self-referential is this even it
i think this is the bigfoot
i'm okay with this yeah
god i feel like that's my spirit animal
right there
i feel like that's you yeah that's yeah
that's your patronus yeah this this six
you on the right yeah
i'm john marston with a six shooter i'm
just a silent hairy man sitting against
a tree
go ahead kill me
anyway zombies like one of the more like
some of the more um
i don't know some of the bigger dlcs
undead nightmare actually kind of went
back to reskin much of red dead
redemption and place undead in this
world and kind of told this story i
forget
what the actual justification was for it
but it was a man
you think i don't exist
how are you so sure you exist
i'm here
maybe we're all bigfoot on the inside
what is he saying
such a model
yeah undead nightmare
undead nightmare is probably a good one
to get into uh another one is enter the
dominatrix that was that clip showed
nothing of undead nightmare but just
imagine dlc b-roll imagine zombies in
red devils and that's undead nightmare
oh here we go john lucas he's back at it
uh enter the dominatrix was originally
teased in april of 2012 as an april
fool's joke dlc for uh saints row 3.
it was never finished
uh and then it ended up being
released as dlc for saints row four and
i didn't really realize how weird it was
until i finally played it like two years
ago uh i think it released it must have
been yeah yeah i get it very very
sex-tinged uh but there are these cut
scenes it's very self-referential they
talk about it's kind of a
parody into
what it's like to make a game or how
games change along the way because there
are these live-action cut scenes of
developers from volition acting out the
scenes really uh that they didn't have
time to finish but they kind like stuff
like this
yeah they don't they get into like how
it was it started as an april fool's
joke and that people wanted it so they
fit into saints row so they just yeah i
kind of want to play this it is it's
very good it's kind of a cool
like i said it's it's all satirical
about maybe not dlc but just how games
are made and it's really funny yeah it's
breaks the fourth wall every which way
and it also calls itself out when it
is not in like canon or when it breaks
congruity with the main game because
it's like a parallel storyline it's
really good i like super want to go back
to saints row four now just like my
phone is that's like in the vein of just
cause kind of that dumb open world fun
uh in saints row you're saint charlie
are actually like a superhero that whole
series evolved so weird the first one
was kind of more grounded uh gritty
like almost like you know chasing after
the gta vibe but then four they just
developed their own weird crazy identity
and enter the dominatrix seems to be the
eight delta guns yes
um volition now is working on agents of
mayhem which has a lot of
the same flavor from that's my patronus
the boy's getting married
this guy
i was gonna say where's the other raptor
oh my god oh no that's me yeah
okay uh that was enter dominatrix
uh more recently i want to talk about
resident evil 7's dlc they've been
pretty
they're releasing a lot of dlc like
right after it came out which i think
served it well it had a long tail as far
as beating those huge releases but
here's birthday party that's weird um
jack baker and he it's this is the more
comical and john luke i know played
through the whole thing but
uh based on the other dlc that played
for this game i didn't get the chance to
play birthday party but it did look
super weird i think john luke and joey
streamed it at some point
um and even the enemies yes he's got
like confetti it's like grunt birthday
party from halo i was gonna say
birthday party but it's got all the
molded enemies have birthday hats on so
if you're scared of this game this is
probably the way to play it right i
guess so but i don't know this scares me
more i was going to say this is pretty
creepy like clowns oh this totally
breaks the like horror vibes no this
creeps me out more i'm more oh it does
not i am i am upset who paid you to say
that
a liar capcom there's someone
behind a camera hearing i just no
uh but yeah
outside of the full homicide outside of
the birthday party dlc horrific you
should definitely if you are a fan of
residential seven play the dlc they've
released uh there's a lot of cool stuff
they do the escape rooms with lucas
um and they kind of you know you can go
back through madhouse difficulty playing
vr this game is fantastic also game of
the year contender in my mind even
though it's only april but just ate a
pepper grinder i want to talk about
okay i'm not scared anymore okay
xcom 2. uh very minor one compared to
these but anarchy's children um
this is just another excuse for me to
talk about xcom 2 because i was gonna
say [ __ ] love this game i was just
playing this yesterday rob you kind of
saw me you might have but uh it
it takes the idea of what if humans
didn't become this just rebellion when
the aliens took over and if they became
this like
punk the purge is the dumbest movie
that's coming to mind right now about
the aesthetic with these mohawks i don't
know just this post-apocalyptic
i mean for lack of a better term i can't
see anarchy
and you can have these sam the lower
face mask part you can have these
samurai like
muzzles it's pretty badass but it also
gets weird in the sense that
some of the outfits are like these [ __ ]
costumes kind of like these tight
leather thing that one's sick i'd wear
that in real
life um there's a lot of mods for this
game so dlc is kind of hard to recommend
an xcom 2 because there's so many mods
that are free that you can just play and
people have implemented stuff like this
but anarchy's children was cool because
it kind of lent a lot more color to your
team
rather than the just militaristic
looking
uh outfits throughout the whole thing
uh yes so moving on to another one that
wasn't
exactly dlc but a spawn from another
game was far cry 3 blood dragon or sorry
far cry blood dragon after far cry 3
this weird project developed became this
80s
um i don't even know how you would
describe it 80s like outrun kind of
cyberpunky
not even cyberpunk it just took like 80s
action movies and made it into a far cry
like a bite-sized tron
yes
without run music and [ __ ] it was really
fun
um and we're still
capitalizing on 80s nostalgia i feel
like with a lot of games releases but
this seemed to kick that off maybe you
end up getting a power glove later on
you punch this reactor destroy the base
it's really fun uh but it's really cool
that it developed like that i think it's
like takes 12 hours as opposed to uh far
cry 3 which took more of a
i don't know 50 hour approach
i just like that it completely changes
the themes like it's just a complete
switch yeah and i love 80s i love 80s
[ __ ] so i was like all about this yeah
it was kind of you know looking back
it's cool that ubisoft green lit this
uh that was pretty sick but yeah play
this if you haven't it's standalone on
xbox 360 ps3 it's worth playing uh cool
and then i just also wanted to touch
more on call of duty zombies we were
talking about it before the show today
um you know as good as most call of duty
games are at least okay zombies is
always really interesting it was just
treyarch but then with uh infinite
warfare's infinity ward's first time
doing it as opposed to some other like
wave based mode but rob and i were
talking i forget how many maps there are
for zombies like 22 or something 23 with
the whole
tons yeah and there's like a continuity
with like the with black ops zombies and
there's it's like there's a whole it's a
whole thing yeah cause there's those
original four characters uh there's a
japanese character a german character
and two americans what that started uh
russian russian and russian oh uh
it's not res no it's not later but uh
yeah it was kind of the people that were
the factions that were included in like
the first uh call of duty world at war
and then they ended up
becoming the first one was i think just
knocked her on totem night of the undead
you seem to know german more than i do
based on conversation this morning
yeah and then you know like
derise came along that was my favorite
yeah that was that was where uh yeah i
was telling you guys when um my buddy
and i would play until like 3 a.m it's
like dude we have class tomorrow we'd
pause it at wave
28 and then go to bed and and try to
pick up where we left off and we were
just so naive like okay you ready okay
i'm paused dead
because you just you develop such a
momentum and a rhythm that you
you can't just
sleep on it and pick it back up the game
is just intense
i would stay up with my brother and play
yeah just they're fun yeah and i think
uh so what was the previous one black
black ops three right black ops three
had like the sort of like
noise this started with the noir one
with uh jeff goldblum was in it they
started getting super weird with uh
celebrity appearances is it danny trejor
or johnny danny trejo uh sarah michelle
geller uh but they actually started
bringing celebrities into it and but
that didn't it didn't at any point feel
like a gimmick because they were just i
mean it's i guess it could but they
they're all quality but here's the the
kind of
zombie swamp from uh the first black eye
or sorry world at war where it started
but this was always a treyarch thing and
then with infinity ward or with infinite
warfare infinity ward took a swing and
they really put their own spin on it
because it's like 80s themes zombies and
spaceland is super fun and they're
really cheeky i really like zombies in
spaceland yeah and uh for those of you
watching this live like i said there
will be a live stream later at 2 p.m
pacific uh scott butterworth and joey
from gamespot will be hosting and
playing with developers from
infinity ward that worked on zombies for
infinite warfare
anyway yeah let us know if we didn't
mention any dlcs that you wanted to hear
talked about let us know twitch chat
youtube chat hit us up on twitter
comment on this if you're watching on
youtube after the fact
cool
uh all right let's get into star wars
i'm sure that's why most people are here
battlefront 2 finally after that leaked
teaser trail or that if that teacher
trailer uh
we know much more about it cali plague
you were down at star wars celebration
in orlando last week i was and you
talked to some of the writers of the
story mode which we saw the trailer for
the last trailer focus more on the
campaign
which the first game was lacking and i
think a lot of people are excited to see
that so i did want to start with story
mode and what they're doing with it uh
what we kind of discerned from the
trailer last week we already talked
about that but between uh i guess all
four of us we have especially youtube we
have a lot of star wars knowledge on the
set today so i want to talk about what
are your uh kind of impressions of story
mode so far what's going on with it um
okay so basically um i'm really excited
for it because it's kind of switching
perspectives it's about an imperial
commander named iden versio um and so
you're kind of they're they're taking
great measures to
to not portray it as like this black and
white good versus evil thing necessarily
it's it's um they're not portraying the
empire's bad guys you really are a
protagonist um in this game from what i
understand
um and i think that's really interesting
and you get to kind of see
what
the
empire views as heroism with regard to
like order instability is very much
an imperial thing and it takes place
right after the events of return of the
jedi so it's picking up in the 30 years
between um that movie and force awakens
so it's kind of exploring this timeline
that we know
pretty
not a lot about
not mainstream right yeah it's not
mainstream for sure i mean like they
talked about the writers talked about
being inspired by aftermath and the
shattered empire comics um which i
thought was really cool um so there's
there's stuff in the existing canon that
that you can kind of base this off of
but they're really trying to explore
something that star wars hasn't really
done yet
so i'm really looking forward to it and
it sounds like um you know it's like an
elite squad it's called the inferno
squadron is what she's part of um
and they're pilots um but also good
boots on the ground sort of soldiers um
and yeah i'm excited yeah rob you looked
you spent most of like yesterday
afternoon kind of looking into the lore
of this can you enlighten us as to what
might be going on plot-wise yeah so uh
you know we've talked about this a bunch
of times and it's yeah it's as cali said
like it's filling in a nice gap that um
has been untold for the most part um but
yeah i i started hitting up the
wookapedia
wikipedia thought that was an accident
when you said it earlier no that's
that's legit got it called
rico village karaoke village
that's a joke
okay and uh yeah i got lost in that
stuff uh and i have some notes on um
what
i think we'll be seeing uh so jean-luc
if you want to roll that b-roll you
might want to like jump around a little
bit but um
yeah
essentially you yeah you play as a
character uh iden right so we're gonna
see this trailer if he yeah i probably
should have trimmed this a little bit
but regardless
so there you have already shots of force
awakens um yeah you just keep moving
along um start killer bass or just play
this john luke i think i timed it so
that's that droid again um it's a secret
droid that you
you can imagine it's like a companion
yeah and they said um in the
presentation that i went to that the
droid is going to um kind of be a big
part of gameplay
so yeah you actually see a little bit of
it in action it's a id9 like seeker
droid and it can walk and talk and
impersonate other droids so i think
there's just an arsenal of abilities it
can have um that you'll probably be
seeing i wonder if it'll kind of play
the part of like uh
i don't know detective vision that's in
so many games now like what was it what
was that uh the thing that eloy used in
horizon focus yeah all right anyway
sorry so this ship um you know we
haven't really seen this before but i
looked it up and it's um
so i believe it's a raider class
corvette which essentially uh
is tasked with like taking down
uh rebel um hidden run ships so it's
like an it's like an anti uh
cruiser for the rebel alliance so it's
like quick and it's got like a single
turbo laser like compared to like a star
square has like multiple series of turbo
lasers so it's got some weapons on it so
you can i would definitely imagine
you're flying this thing in some uh
space battles in the single player
campaign if you keep going oh and top
right there that
this was weird pausing it that's a uh
mon calamari cruiser
and this clearly seems to be
not a fight or battle scene so i don't
know what the hell that thing's doing
really what we're doing here in the
fleet yeah i mean no one's like
attacking it like maybe it's like
captured in the beginning because this
is again death star 2 so there's no
conflict right now so it's kind of
interesting maybe no one sees it
sure
superstar destroyer there
obviously you remember from uh
the return of jedi movie maybe there's
some action there with that thing uh and
i believe in the uh description of
multiplayer you the space battles will
have
um like takedowns of uh massive enemy
cruisers so maybe there's um some of
that going on space battles in
multiplayer or even single player uh and
again there's the the droid again you
see it actually shocking a rebel trooper
um
here's the wreckage there uh yeah so
this is if you keep going this is where
it gets really uh
interesting so here's post
jedi right everyone's um bolting so what
i was looking up and again this was in
shattered comet uh shattered empire
uh back that actually shot no just keep
playing john luke but that's actually uh
uh
takadana from force awakens but those
are actually uh
uh original trilogy tie fighters oppose
the new or first order tie fighters
which is really weird that they're going
back to that planet so this is the
coolest stuff right here so that guy
it's like who is this dude he is a
sentinel and in the shattered empire
comics
he after the empire died
he or the emperor died he realized uh he
needs to basically have a if i die i
need to have these commands so he has
these droids that's like a like a
dressed up uh uh you know royal guard uh
droid there that will deliver his final
commands
and this is all lore there's something
called the contingency
which is basically when he goes the
emperor says if i die
destroy the empire and he has these guys
carry out orders so he's telling her
more most likely like
this is now my next plan here he is in
the comics um he would do things like he
had a prong so he would pierce your skin
and get like a blood sample and see if
you're actually legit who you were
before he like relayed uh the plans
essentially as one does is that why you
call them prongs
prongs needles
no i was joking
uh so he's got the face of the emperor
on him uh and one of his first plants or
after uh endor um the battle of endor
his first plan was
uh the battle of naboo so we had
um
the emperor as you know from the
prequels was born on that planet as a
center from that planet
the emperor wanted to basically erase
all ties of him being a sith so he had
basically the the empire go this planet
attack it use these satellites to create
hurricanes on the planet flood the
capital of naboo which is feed which
evidently is a map in this game they say
at the bottom feed is something you'll
play in multiplayer
and have his staff basically throw and
destroy all the sith like relics he had
um
and then with the final stages of his
contingency plan was
to at some point eliminate all officers
other than like a few higher ups and
have those officers then flee to the
outer rim
one of them being uh forget his first
name but uh actually i wrote that down
what was his name
i did not but it's hard to start like
the first order to start the first order
and one of them being hux his son is the
uh admiral hux that you know from the
force awakens so that's super neat like
yeah you're going to see you're going to
see the start of the first order and
whether or not she's a part of it we'll
have to see yeah and when i talked to
them there they worked very closely with
lucasfilm to make sure this is all you
know it fits into the continuity they
don't like using the term canon but
that's like the easiest way to describe
it um but like they've created a new
planet
and um
they
are they really they're focusing on
exploring
what happens to the empire after the
emperor and um so a lot of that from
shattered empire kind of coincides with
what they were saying
so yeah i'd say that's pretty spot on
yeah you were talking you're talking to
some of the writers right mitch dyer
used to be at ign but now he's working
here on this game yes so
william full disclosure i used to work
with mitch dyer at ign um but he's
working on this game now uh with motive
studios um and
i was getting um
a lot of rogue one vibes um from just
the tone um and what they were saying
about the game and uh it seems like for
them rogue one kind of validated what
they were already doing um with this
story so i would imagine it's going to
be tonally at least a little bit more in
that vein than than maybe you know what
you're used to with the original trilogy
at least or even you know force awakens
kind of like uh focus more on one squad
a lot banned a brother saving private
ryan or even i don't know it's
interesting to see like rumors about the
next call of duty going back to world
war ii you have to wonder like maybe
people are focusing more i mean this
says like the untold soldier story but
it's interesting to see where it go
especially because walt williams wrote
uh helped write spec ops the line right
so the other writer yeah he he wrote
spec ops the line so i'm very interested
to see um
what
where this story goes and what um tactic
they take with it yeah you want it to be
fun especially because it's
the first single-player campaign since
battlefront 2 which had like galactic
conquest and the those story modes which
were kind of uh they were the campaigns
for all four factions but it would still
be interesting to see things from the
empire's perspective especially after
it's just shattered you mentioned halo
reach as a comparison like you know
things won't end well but you still kind
of enjoy the ride while you're playing
it um yeah so i'm curious to see where
it goes especially after the lore you
were talking about when you were talking
to the writers down in orlando last week
cool uh let us know what you think if
you noticed anything the trailer that we
didn't if you have read aftermath or a
shattered empire let us know if you have
any theories about what we might see in
battlefront 2 and releases november 17th
of this year yes and be sure to check
out our everything we know so far if you
have any questions lays out basically
the story and um kind of what the
details are yeah and i know jean-luc is
working on one of his like history of
pieces he's doing a history of
battlefront i think that'll be up maybe
this weekend maybe next week we're not
positive yet but you should check that
out if you haven't played a battlefront
or if you haven't played in a while you
kind of want to get back into it
cool
uh now just moving out to multiplayer it
seems like the other
side of this two-headed dog you saw it
and it's apparently in terms of overall
like meta progression and stuff it's
super different than the first game yeah
so i um the actual interview i had at
star wars celebration was about
multiplayer and the biggest change is
going to be the progression system
they're trying to
give it more longevity and trying to
keep you coming back to multiplayer um
and with that they're giving both
troopers and heroes progression and then
that progression unlocks kind of um
customization i mean obviously like
darth maul's gonna be darth maul like
you're not gonna be like i have darth
maul with a gun you know but like um you
you're going to be able to um give them
sort of a career and then they also
talked about wanting this quote here
this is um
uh bernder
who i talked to um
from dice and uh they wanted heroes to
not just be like quick pickups they
didn't really specify but it was he
talked about a resource-based system
that um as you can see here gives them a
little bit more uh presence more like
he sort of described it as being like
weightier like having them kind of
occupy more space on the field and i
wasn't exactly sure what that meant um
but it seems like it's going to be a a
little easier or just different the
process of getting heroes is going to be
different as opposed to just those
tokens that just pop up make sure
i remember when i covered uh scarif i
like could not
find the you know
uh
generiso like icon like i would stalk
and wait for an area and i would see
guys like doing the same thing it's you
know you're not participating in that
point in the first battlefront uh rogue
one dlc you mean correct yeah yeah um
but yeah so did you get to see the
progression system in action was this
all just uh kind of them telling you
about it no this was just talking to um
people from motive and dice
there's we really don't have a lot of
footage the only thing we got for
multiplayer from that trailer was just
seeing different heroes that are going
to appear like the trailer says it's
heroes from all eras um so
yeah just to clarify people watching
this live right now this is the first
battlefront from ea and dice this is uh
we just we don't have much footage from
the second one so we threw this up to
come uh compare it kind of you know you
pick up a token then depending on the
planet you get the hero in this case
luke skywalker on hoth yeah um but as
cali is saying it's more tied to
uh just like completing different
actions maybe in a more battlefield kind
of way right you don't have to just get
kills to contribute to something you can
actually like be a support character a
healer maybe because uh burn dimer who's
what was up earlier um he's from dice uh
i would imagine maybe there's some sort
of connection there with how it works in
battlefront i don't know yeah or
battlefield um
it really wasn't clear and i was like oh
well are heroes specific to planets and
they were like maybe i was like okay um
the other cool thing is that troopers
are specific to the location and era
you're on because they're trying to keep
it
more i think you said more authenticity
um the aesthetic of the soldiers are but
not the loadouts you can those are carry
across planets yes so it's basically a
skin and york that's tied to the
progression system so your career
trooper is going to be the same you're
not going to have to like restart
because now i'm in the clone wars era
and now i have to start over i think
they even mentioned on their site that
they'll have separate modes uh catered
to like the mix and match of like darth
maul
and kylo ren yeah you know hitting the
town like i think they'll have at least
those
steps
kylo ren is such a miranda
so darth maul is a samantha maybe
no carrie he's a carrie i don't know sex
in the city that too right this is bell
front too correct yes count dooku on uh
tatooine it's kind of look at that thing
who's that little guy no it's joking uh
i've i'm into the more like if count
dooku was a character on friends who
would he be oh my god he is such a ross
like i've never thought about that until
now mace windu would be such a monika
oh is this just hero brawl the yeah i
was wondering i was like why are they
all there um yeah i'm all like they'll
definitely do that it sounds like on
flip i would i would really hope that
they have uh game mode or playlists that
are uh you know stripped maybe of these
heroes because that's just yeah yeah
something i i personally don't really
care for
yeah yeah i really really we i've talked
about this every time that we've talked
about battlefront 2 so far i hope that
they borrow from things what they did
with battlefield 1 both of them being
something dice worked on um but like the
first battlefront was very if you're a
star wars fan it was fun for a few hours
at least it was for me but then after a
while it kind of just lost its substance
and i felt like it was all just
spectacle surface appeal i hope they're
actually maybe the progression system
will help i know progression systems are
nothing new and i know that's kind of
become a staple since like modern
warfare right um i still
think that could give it the legs that
the first one didn't have i agree i mean
i think i think they recognize that and
i think they're taking steps to rectify
that with battlefront 2. um
but i mean
i i agree with rob i would rather have
an option to just kind of not have
heroes although they did mention that um
one of the things they they took care to
do was not make heroes feel overpowered
they wanted if you
weren't playing a hero to be able to
take down here like feel like you were
on a level playing field so i'm a little
i'm not exactly sure how that will work
um
we just really need to see more of it in
action i think but um as far as what
they're saying um with what's changed it
seems like they've recognized the
problems with the first battlefront yeah
we talked about last week pete you said
that you were kind of tired of seeing
like han solo corkscrewing across the
battlefield and just
specifically i love no
it was the emperor doing barrel rolls
right that's what it was and then han
solo was just
i don't know what was he doing sitting
again tree questioning the meaning of
life dapper you're still in that bigfoot
thing aren't you yeah you're still
thinking you've not moved on since then
so i haven't said anything yeah
yeah the other thing about the
progression system too now that i'm
thinking about is without the last
battlefront was that everything was
locked behind a currency and that's
including
you know i mean here it is you had hut
contracts you had to basically um like
i think it was just too much maintenance
and work opposed to just like you know
the subconscious idea of like the more i
play i'm just going to unlock more
weapons opposed to like all right well i
have you know 2 000 credits whatever it
is where am i going to put that i sure
saw i'm not going to put it into any
cosmetics like that's one thing you know
i mean like
i never got or played as much as i would
have uh to the point where i was like
all right you know what i've unlocked
i've unlocked everything now it's time
to maybe focus on like how i look as a
storm trooper
i don't know who captured this but that
was pretty dumb to call in while you're
in the middle of the hallway getting
shot he's gonna be dead by the time he's
back maybe he knew he was gonna die he
bounced down maybe it was you capturing
it no yeah
excuse me when you get in the vehicle
you disappear so i just saved my ass
defense i forgot in this game you're not
you're immediately safe it's a get out
of jail free card you warp to a tie
fighter that makes sense
i don't know why i'm calling out the
logic in star wars but it's all good
it's always been physically
sound star wars it's not like hard
sci-fi but it's the fantasy dude
yeah and here's space battles and you
know what's nice is that uh you know
criterion who made the vr uh x-wing
mission they like from the ground up
reworked all the flight controls and
they they felt so much better compared
to uh
the vanilla game yeah yeah i do have
some questions about battlefront uh some
of from the story that i didn't get to
earlier but
uh grant wilson on twitter was asking do
we think battlefront 2 will keep the bad
guys the bad guys or will they switch
sides uh do you think they're gonna
stick to that
like uh are you are the empire the whole
thing or is it gonna end up just
becoming this moral gray ground
it really seems like they're trying to
give you a different perspective and not
just frame the empire as as objectively
bad it's more like see where they're
coming from sort of thing i think it's
not like gray jedi stuff on like a
personnel level probably more than
anything right
so this is uh mark thompson from motive
studios um
and yeah so
iden they're
like he says here um they're trying to
just kind of put you in somebody else's
shoes and it's not clear if they're
going to
uh like i mean i imagine that maybe
there'll be like a come to jesus moment
where you're like oh man the emperor was
real bad i don't know but um so but it
seems like they're taking a nuanced
approach with it was it rob's you not to
keep making comparisons like banner
brothers but there's that episode of
band of brothers where they're in uh
austria and kind of
you know or no bavaria and they're just
saying kind of
looking at what it meant to be like a
boots on the ground soldier for the the
nazis as opposed to this like third
reich officer and then that's also when
like germany had collapsed at that point
and the allied forces were across the
rhine and everything kind of reminds me
of something like that like the downfall
i don't know because i mean like
stormtroopers and whatnot always being
kind of like a stand-in for
nazis well yeah i mean there's a
difference between being i mean like an
18-year-old
kid on the german side is the same as an
18 year old kid on the american side you
know so it's uh it's sort of a similar
vein but ident is a commander so
she has
more power than
ever
yeah she's she's more than than the
average stormtrooper and so yeah maybe
that'll
be the difference maybe they'll examine
that i don't know yeah i mean you know
it's just like world war ii like it's a
series of just propaganda and
brainwashing like you're led to believe
the emperor is
awesome well at force awakens remember
when uh when finn is showing signs of
kind of
you just got a poster of him on your
ceiling
that's something they actually said is
that the kind of character they're
trying to build here the inferno squad
which is um the ident squad is kind of
the the people you would put on the
propaganda poster to inspire
uh you know empire kids to want to fight
for the emperor like that's the kind of
character they're going for so right in
the chat twitch chat
i know what i'm talking about it's
banner brothers go watch it if you
haven't seen it
you just proved his point but
yeah you've seen banana brothers you
know what i'm talking about if you
haven't then go watch it all right cool
or i was gonna say go check out the uh
subreddit i think it's a subreddit
called the empire the empire did nothing
wrong
it's like there are people who just
like scan and scour all the movies and
just look for like see like
like the whole thing about the death
star that's i think this is now not
considered canon but that the emperor
made the death star because uh every
like 10 000 years this like out just
very much the plot of mass effect no
that's what the reapers come along yeah
they come and they like wipe out the
whole universe
or the galaxy death or even like
prepping for that halos
it's really funny
you know i
really love the dark side i was always a
darth vader girl i had a crush on anakin
skywalker i was like he's dreamy i had
the biggest crush he's that's when he's
middle-aged what has happened when he's
on music
oh my god no a lot
i have the high ground cali the empire
could
i would
sure they did
not maybe some
all the things
all right anyway if you're in the twitch
chat youtube chat if you're watching
this afterwards on youtube let us know
what you think of battlefront 2 whether
you plan on playing multiplayer whether
you're excited for the campaign uh
whether you're excited to see things
from the empire's perspective let us
know
cool but uh like i had mentioned i think
this is good as good week as any there
have been rumors out about uh the new
call of duty is gonna be
you know kind of revealed sometime
soonish in the coming weeks from uh
sledgehammer games it's their turn in
that three studio rotation for call of
duty games uh but also like we just said
battlefront 2 is focusing more boots on
the ground from the empire's perspective
it's also one of the writers from spec
ops the line
very very good game kind of took a look
at what it like
shoot what it means to kind of be doing
screwed up stuff because you're being
told to in war uh but walt williams is
also writing battlefront 2 with a few
other people
at ea motive but we figured it'd be a
good time
because of all this to talk about our
favorite war games our favorite games
about war not necessarily like spec ops
they critique it but sometimes they're
just fun like i don't know red alert 2
is one of my favorite games
and that's a really dumb look at war
it's like
uh you have yuris like in the expansion
yuri's friends you have like this this
faction that kind of has like brain
control [ __ ] and then you have tanya you
can have an army of tonya's crawling
across with c4s blowing up bass but uh
we already mentioned it i want to talk
about spec ops the line quick because we
talked about so much uh have you guys
all played it
no but i watched uh chris waters
wonderful video review this morning i
missed that guy yeah he knows how to
write a beautiful script yeah
it's uh it's a really cool game we
to pimp something that jake decker and i
are doing our next episode of reboot the
show we've been working on is about uh
war in games and kind of uh games that
portray it well games that critique what
it means to be playing a soldier in a
game and
whether it should be fun and i mean how
they make war games fun in general but
also uh yeah we talked a lot about spec
ops and this is an important game in
that i really don't
i know the statute of limitations
probably lifted but i still am hesitant
to generation
i know but i'm still hesitant to spoil
this if you're watching now and you
haven't played it just because
the ending is super integral to the game
and why it's important i mean yeah if
most people are not spoiling it
it's cool it it uh it makes you actually
it's kind of the bioshock of war games
almost it examines what you're doing and
why you're doing it and how you're doing
what you're told and how you factor into
like
screwed up things that are really
happening despite the fact that it's a
game and it's just a fun game but then
you know like they kind of call you out
for thinking that but it's uh it's a
really good game like i said first
same writer as battlefront 2's campaign
one of them uh walt williams it's uh
that's this is from developer jaeger but
uh kelly you said you've you played this
i mean you've you've said most of the
things like yeah it's tough i don't want
to spoil anything yeah i just i like i
like uh
an examination of why we find this sort
of thing fun i mean i i grew up playing
shooters which is a weird sentence um
and
it's important to reflect i i think i
think it's important to reflect on why
you enjoy that sort of thing and it was
important for me at least so
sorry he was just doing a really like
unrealistic thing oh there's
things yeah i was like that is super
weird did you see that we were talking
about mitch dyer writing battlefront and
then in this video review in the lobby
it was chris waters and mitch dyer
really
that's weird uh
yes but anyway
we are
yeah like i said if you get the chance
on sunday go check out reboot at 3pm uh
we talk more about spec ops uh but it's
also one last thing it's kind of based
around apocalypse now or heart of
darkness kind of looking at going down
this like long river to colonel kurtz or
whatever this
a wall general uh anyway
kelly you wanna talk about modern
warfare i wanted to before i really want
to talk about modern warfare um a game
that we all hate not a show
i love this game uh yeah i mean i played
modern warfare remastered um obviously
and i think it's aged really well um my
favorite mission is and i don't care
about spoiling this because it's not the
end um is when you
have to save the helicopter pilot um the
helicopter's crashed um and
i think it's called charlie don't surf
is that the same one uh is charlie don't
surf the one before i think it is this
is charlie don't surf right here so yeah
you might write so it's the one right
before um you have to save her and
there's a time limit and no matter how
quickly you do it you you get nuked
anyway you die anyway um
and
when i first played this game that was
i hadn't really played a game where like
i couldn't succeed
um and it was
i just sat there and thought about it
for a really long time i remember and
when i played it again i
uh
having come off of you know black ops 3
or even infinite warfare where you're
like super powered and you can do
anything and you're moving really
quickly you go to modern warfare and
you're moving you're clambering over
[ __ ] and like you
are getting bombed out and you have to
like
really
you you have to really try especially if
you're playing on hardened or veteran
and um i just liked that slowdown i
liked going back to
something that felt more
human than
being able to wall run and jump jetpack
out of whatever situation like i you
can't jetpack out of this you know oh
you
yeah to segway actually you just remind
me of this mission but where i was gonna
go into was uh again not
by any means uh realistic but like halo
reach
um
had that same ending
and as a huge halo fan playing that game
it was the first time where uh
you know you you play as master chief or
even arbiter just these really
overpowered super soldiers in that game
you had a squad you had people that
weren't just generic scripted you know
grunts from aliens who just had the same
like two three lines these are people
who were like sacrificing their lives
like for you and one by one like the
last few um few hours of that game where
like as again someone who's playing that
uh that series was like this is
uncomfortable in a good way
[Music]
to crack more and more yeah
by this point uh catherine halsey the
scientist that's kind of in charge of
spartan program and you're transporting
cortana to the drop ship to give two you
find out later master chief this takes
place right before they do the slip
space jump the random one which you're
not supposed to do because you have no
idea where in the universe or the galaxy
you'll end up but they end up at halo
and then pillar of autumn mission starts
from halo combat evolved
and there's that easter egg in the
cutscene if you hold the right the stick
to the right you can look over and see
master chief in his cryo really yeah
it's really cool uh this game is
fantastic again i i keep mentioning it
but it's almost like that's saving
private ryan it's a small squad with
personalities yeah so when someone dies
you feel it all the more it's like the
vin diesel scene which sucks and same
private ryan or uh forget what's the the
one-on-one scene with the knife or the
stabbing that part's always tough to
watch but this game gets pretty
emotional it's really
impressive that you know the whole time
you're gonna lose
in the end but it's still fun throughout
yeah and i mean some people on your
squad like didn't necessarily die very
heroic right they would just be like
a sniper shot from you know a jackal
like jeez like
you just you know it left you uh
with very abrupt like ways of dying and
it was uncomfortable yeah yeah going
back to modern warfare really quickly
there's an achievement um for it's like
super early on in the game but if
they're you're like in a stairwell and i
forget what level it is but um you can
get an achievement for like saving this
kid because like uh an enemy will just
come and like stab him and i didn't i
did it and i didn't even know there's an
achievement for it like i had forgotten
and um i don't know what about it like
everybody in your squad has a name and i
don't know what about it like stuck with
me like the fact that i saved him on
accident and i was like oh wow he could
have easily died
and he's not a real person but like that
happens in real life all the time i
don't know what it was it just really
messed me up yeah someone's mentioning
also the no russian mission from modern
warfare 2. we saw that uh
yeah that was uh bushin ryukat on twitch
was saying are you guys gonna talk about
modern warfare 2's level no russian that
was surreal
uh if you don't know that's the one
where you kind of you don't have to
start opening up fire but you're in the
airport and you're uh you're like
undercover with these russians you start
just shooting civilians in the airport
and you don't actually have to
but they kind of heavily incur not
encourage you but yeah you can see it
right here but they kind of heavily
say and then it's kind of like scary
this is also
what 2008
2009
yeah like what the
i forget how
it's oh my god it's so upsetting
that that's actually one thing about
minor warfare again we talked a lot
about that on reboot this weekend it's
it was weird um my brother did three
tours in iraq with the marines and then
two in afghanistan and as opposed to the
world war ii games that call of duty had
always done uh modern warfare came along
and then it's fictional kind of combines
cold warfares of nukes and russia being
the enemy with
terrorism and uh you know like
insurgents from the middle east that you
always saw in cnn but
it was weird to be
playing a game portraying a conflict
that was currently happening
uh and that was kind of weird i mean
that was the first time i felt
uncomfortable but then yeah this came
along what the [ __ ] is going on that is
i don't think they pulled that off at
all no i don't know
so uncomfortable i mean i mean if you
were around at that time it was so
controversial that like you can opt not
to play it yeah um like couldn't sell it
in like germany or something um some
some
european country was like nah like [ __ ]
off with that
um
yeah it it is a very weird shift because
i mean you start out playing like
like i personally started out on like
doom and quake and then i played like
world war ii shooters and then you get
into this sort of thing which is like
you said like a real
conflict that is happening and
you see you know the insurgents kill a
president and
it's
like it's much more real because it's
not as distant as something like world
war ii world war ii was always like
glorified
um it's also like kind of more black and
white i guess good versus evil well yeah
it's very easy to be like we all know
that nazis are evil it's like fine but
uh
yeah there's much more
you feel bad
yeah i mean i love that i love modern
warfare i love that game
yeah and there's also it also has those
dumb military like stay frosty marines
things that i'm like oh okay i i'm
playing remastered and being like oh
yeah i forgot when we all thought that
was cool yeah if you're playing mass
effect andromeda there's a classic line
right under the ice planet uh stay extra
frosty oh
yeah
to crawl out of this depressing hole and
also out of that awful
bit of writing pete you wanted to
mention something a little more that you
could
any time you get [ __ ] use mike yes uh
final fantasy tactics is a game about
war obviously it's sort of like a
medieval fantasy sort of thing so it's
not war the way that we've been talking
about wars right
um but what it deals with is sort of
like you know who controls the history
books after a conflict right usually the
people who win
but you know when you when you do that
you sort of lose touch of all the actual
events that happen so this game actually
shows you the events as they occurred
versus as how history remembers them uh
in this world and the things that sort
of lead to
a certain person winning and then
rewriting the history books uh has a lot
to do with like class warfare has a lot
to do with how religion sort of inspires
people uh to do things to cause wars uh
and you know something like that now
this game is a little bit hard to follow
because especially the the naming of a
lot of characters and places and events
is very rapid and it's very odd you have
characters named gaf gary on
deleta like things that just sound
really really strange but so you may
have to play this game a few times to
really get everything but it's a really
curious examination of the manipulation
of uh people events and information
around war
you said i mean like in strategy games
like this kind of top down isometric or
i mean like i wanted to talk about xcom
2 really briefly because that's the game
i always try to talk about when i get
the chance but i've already talked about
it once yeah i know but i'm gonna again
we
i i always get kind of attached to
characters in games like this when i
know like all their abilities and their
i don't know like fire emblem comes to
mind too but i know what how they play
into my squad and my team overall do you
get the sense from that do you actually
get attachments to these characters are
they kind of just these uh veneers well
you do i mean there are some characters
that can never um die permanently but
most of the characters in your party
will which includes your starting cast
and some characters that you pick up
throughout the story that are like you
know like special characters right like
one-off classes and stuff like that
but you can even you know dismiss troops
and and stuff like that if you need to
make room in your party and uh these
characters they all have these like
lines that they give where they feel
like what am i not good enough like i'm
so sorry i didn't mean to let you down
like are you really gonna cast me aside
and um and so maybe even if they're not
dying even if you're just shuffling them
around you can feel bad for them
um your guts are hanging out of your
stomach clearly you're not good enough
get out of here go die no i'm just
kidding i wouldn't do that but yeah this
is um
if you consider the sort of like aspects
of shut up certain aspects of war that
drive something like game of thrones
because there is kind of like an
overarching war behind all of that
um apart from you know the wall and all
that [ __ ] but
um
this this game is really good in that
sort of vein and
uh really just kind of keeps you
guessing from beginning to end in terms
of like who's really in control and who
is the one uh who has the most at stake
um
at war you've been telling me to play
this for a long time oh yeah i've been
telling a lot of people i should yeah
it's the best way to play this
damn there's like two sequels that came
out uh tactics advance and texas
advanced two a2 is on gb uh advanced but
don't around ds but don't play those
play this one um either the playstation
class x version on your vita psp ps3
um or you can also do the war of the
lions which is sort of like an updated
version that is on ios psp and ps vita
cool
um
i also rob you already talked about halo
reach a little bit when we were talking
about uh battlefront but
uh yeah there are a couple other
standouts that actually kind of take a
cool look this war of mine is more
focused on the civilians and how they're
affected it's like an eastern european
conflict but you have to just survive in
these uh yeah [ __ ] the war right there
you can see on that rock
you are uh civilian surviving in this
eastern european conflict and you
essentially
every time you play it's kind of a
procedural in terms of how long it'll
take but you have to just survive until
a ceasefire is called which is
completely out of your control um and
you're just kind of doing kind of you
see a fallout shelter perspective on
this a lot darker than fallout shelter
though uh you know the i think the
something the children is the dlc for it
and it comes it introduces kids into it
and you have to kind of take care of
them as well but yeah you have to decide
who your enemies are yeah who uh
i don't know it's it's who your enemies
are and who your teammates are and how
this all factors into how the civilians
get affected um because it's you know
like kind of talking about how
this is their war the way they perceive
that even though they weren't fighting
in the overall conflict uh it's it's
it's also just
maybe not fun but it's also really
rewarding um managing these teams like
kind of you were talking about final
fantasy tactics here i guess xcom 2 you
get attached to these characters
throughout each play through and you're
like okay this person's good at lock
picking or cooking this person is useful
for that but then you start seeing them
on a more emotional level and it's
pretty rewarding i suggest trying that
out it was the playstation plus free
game last month or sorry like three
months ago actually
um yeah it's worth playing if you
haven't
um any others that you want to mention
that i didn't yes that reminded me um i
want to talk about papers please a
little bit
um
sorry john luke for not prepping you on
that uh
but uh yeah something that's not about
actually fighting in the war um and it's
also eastern european well like a fake
eastern european country papers please
um if you aren't familiar with it you
have to
um kind of look at people's documents
and either let them into like let them
across the border or deny them um and
if you get i almost forget how it works
but i just remember being like haunted
by the sound effects because like you
can hear
like
i don't know it's like very simple and
and
yeah you decided
yeah but like the the act of deciding
who you let in yeah it's really tough
because in the beginning it's just about
making sure that like okay i need to
have these pieces of information yeah
and they have these pieces of
information so they're good to go but
then people come up and admit to you
that like i don't have my documents but
i'm escaping an abusive husband exactly
i need to get across the border here's
like a thousand dollars please please
let me across and you can do that but
you might get caught you don't want to
yeah you're avoiding getting caught and
because you are also making a
like a pittance um to support your
family and you have to like pay your
bills um
and
it gets really emotional when people are
like please just please let me in and
you have to like yeah like you can see
here you're kind of verifying that they
are from where they say they are
and
it's
so simple and it seems like a
a game about doing a menial task would
be boring but it's i couldn't stop
playing it when it came out it came out
like what 2012 2013 yeah something
around then yeah it's worth checking out
it's uh it's easy to play in kind of
like bite-sized chunks too but
it's kind of interesting to think that
what seems to be seems to be the most
tedious and boring job
you know like i just think of like a guy
at the airport like just checking your
your your stuff your passport what's the
game as last year where you're like a
customer service rep i get this call
every day yeah less uh moral
implications but still kind of a similar
thing
but yeah so uh those are kind of a few
of the games we want to talk about
whether they were just fun games or kind
of took a cool look at war again on
sunday we have something going up uh
about how games portray war and how they
might be able to do better based on some
of these games uh bus and was it
pushing
uh the opening normandy beach for
frontline uh medal of honor was what i
wanted to say just because like it was i
think it was like the first time where
like i had like my parents watched me
play it and they both were like
wow video games are kind of cool or like
you know
pretty intense yeah why are you playing
yeah well that was the one thing but
like it was the first time when she was
like i remember my mom was like wow like
that's pretty heavy honestly i think
allied assault was the first normandy
beach invasion in a game and then
frontline came along if i'm not mistaken
i just thought it was on pc metal on the
front lines normandy in the atari 2600
was pretty good
i had the opposite thing where my dad
was like hey check this game out and we
played it and it was intense yeah but
yeah good call because that game we were
talking that kind of becomes like a
james bond movie halfway through this
undercover agent going into german
u-boats and sneaking behind enemy lines
and going to that dinner party where you
have to be stealthy a little bit but i
guess the stealth's kind of rudimentary
in hindsight man i forgot the entire
game clearly stealthy about taking food
from other people's plates
slipping eye drops into people you don't
like their wine um not that i do that in
real life uh anyway yeah let us know if
we forgot to mention any uh like i said
with uh call of duty announcements
supposedly coming soon we'll know more
about that from sledgehammer games uh
battlefront 2 is focusing more on its
campaign this time around with a couple
of uh writers who have kind of had
experience and uh like with spec ops the
line and uh yeah we're excited for those
so uh and dawn of war i guess that's
more fantasy war but an rts game that
will release next week our review will
be up soonish tomorrow tomorrow if
you're watching this live it'll be
tomorrow april
20th sorry just kidding what does that
mean 4 20.
what what did you do what is that
nothing i didn't do anything all right
let us know in the comments thanks
cool
that's a show
uh
yeah again we have that uh can you uh we
have the pixel pals giveaway can you get
those ryu and chun li uh khaleesi plays
in the twitch chat just again the lobby
giveaway if you're on twitch she just uh
put that link in there so if you don't
follow games on twitter do so please and
retweet that tweet later in the week if
you're in north america we'll pick a
random winner and you'll get these sent
to your residence cave or hovel whatever
you happen to live in here we go or
under
here we go do over under this time here
you go get your ugly coffee cup out of
here you're ugly cool uh later on 2 p.m
pacific scott butterworth joey will be
hosting a uh
call of duty zombies the new dlc pack
live stream with some of the developers
from infinity ward who worked on zombies
just one developer
with one of the developers who worked on
zombies who's the fourth person playing
there's only three there's only three
okay but yeah so that'll be on later uh
thursday tomorrow the triforce what's
the theme this week
arizona you don't know yet super well no
it's just mysterious we could we could
say it but do you know we are going to
close the book on triforce really
we just can't
we can't
do anymore i don't know there's running
out of ideas the audience has been great
like it's been fun to do but like as we
watch the rest of the internet kind of
like pick this game apart and we watch
our own sort of interest begin to fade
it's like wow what can we do that people
haven't seen already well
a lot of the ideas we we thought we
would have were like you know
just physics like the game is is very
plentiful and that type of stuff but
then you you get into like okay look you
know the whole flying thing where you
could take mine carts and fly
as you're doing it
it's super boring you know what i mean
like you think it's a cool thing to show
off but you can't do that for an hour
and a half so
you know if there's one thing that we
all know zelda breath of wild is uh
is known for at the moment is speed
running so we're gonna we're gonna take
a stab at it we're gonna try to
start a game unintended
and stab at some rocks that you climb
onto subsequently
yeah yeah that's right i don't know if
you saw any of the speedrun he's hitting
you know like boulders on all the
mountains and stuff like that yeah he's
leaving a shrine or does this a couple
times and does the whole stace trick in
order to get like the type of time yeah
i just find it fascinating how people
are like developing these
uh methods um
but yeah i think we're gonna try to do
it yeah so join us tomorrow for that uh
11 a.m pacific 11 a.m and if you haven't
watched all tri-force you want to watch
a good episode watch the one from two
weeks ago
i can't see [ __ ] yeah that was so good
that was fun uh and exhausting i think
uh
definitely what i'll do is uh at some
point when we close the book i'll
combine them all and do a nice little
highlight compilation of all the
episodes we've done cool
all right anyway uh everybody thank you
so much for stopping by we will be back
next week same time as always uh i don't
know what are you up to the rest of the
week the weekend aside from triforce
maybe some near maybe near automotive
yeah yeah i'll uh can't talk i'm also
looking at the retrofreak console which
some people might know about uh it's a
system that plays
old nes super nintendo genesis game boy
and turbo graphics games from all
regions it's pretty neat um should we
get this since we can't get an nes
classic now uh
well there's another system i just got
in
that is another nes
made by different company so i don't
know we'll see then let's look at both
of these systems right what about you
aside from triforce
watching the last jedi trailer a lot
more no i can't watch that really
anymore
um i don't really know you know any
plans
[Music]
yeah i might do another feature give us
a plan now like make something up uh
uh
uh i'll see if i can put my foot in my
mouth
that's your friday but i've seen you do
you pay him before you can do that uh
callie about you and if i put you on the
spot please just tell me right now
before we get
uh playing more mario kart uh i think we
might be doing a tournament that i'm
determined to win so i'm going to
practice
um and that's probably what i'll do
all weekend and that review will be up
manana on gamespot manana manana.com dot
gamespot twitchtv.spot
uh i'm jetting off to portland in like
an hour i don't know get out of here no
one cares dude
[Laughter]
you're just mad because i'm not because
i can think of my plans
hey man i will also be trying to put my
foot in my mouth on the plane
maybe i would hate this next to you
marshall's like i don't even know if i'm
supposed to like arrest him for this
what is he doing
i got an aisle seat so it actually seems
very possible i'll try report back
there's wi-fi on the plane i'll be live
tweeting trying to shove my foot in my
mouth hey i'll end the show when i want
to yeah watch me mute you
yeah you're muted bye see bye
[Music]
do
you